vemos que aquí tenemos un diagrama donde
se muestra una masa que deberíamos
conceptualizar como un punto de masa
aunque aquí no se ve como un punto
parece un círculo pero imaginemos que es
un punto de masa y está amarrado a algo
mediante una hipotética cuerda sin masa
que está amarrada a un clavo y está
encima de una superficie sin fricción
imaginemos que esta masa tiene cierta
velocidad aquí tenemos la magnitud de su
velocidad en la dirección que es
perpendicular a la cuerda que está unida
a la masa podríamos decir que es
perpendicular a la dirección radial con
base en esto tenemos una definición para
momento angular la magnitud del momento
angular va a ser igual a la masa
multiplicada por esta velocidad
multiplicada por el radio y también
podemos ver esto con lo cual estamos
viendo algunas conexiones entre las
nociones de traslación y de rotación
podemos decir que el momento angular es
lo mismo que la masa por la velocidad la
podemos ver como el momento traslacional
la magnitud del momento traslacional en
esta dirección
x r el concepto traslacional x r y
tenemos la idea rotacional el momento
angular comparado con el momento
traslacional y también podemos ver esto
en términos de la velocidad angular
esto viene directo de la idea de que
esta vez va a ser igual a omega r
hicimos esa sustitución y obtenemos esta
fórmula de acá en vídeos anteriores
dijimos que con base en esto y con la
idea de que el torque permanece
constante entonces esto no va a cambiar
y podemos describir y explicar el tipo
de comportamiento que vemos en una
patinadora sobre hielo en donde esta
patinadora contrae sus brazos los pega
hacia su cuerpo y sin aplicar más torque
a sus giros cuando pegan sus brazos esto
se va a mantener constante porque no
estamos aplicando ningún torque
adicional la masa tampoco va a cambiar
por lo
que la patinadora va a girar más
rápidamente si se hace lo opuesto pues
ocurrirá lo contrario pero quizás
ustedes se quedaron un poco
insatisfechos en ese momento porque yo
les dije que si no teníamos un torque
neto entonces el momento angular se
mantiene constante y vemos que ocurre
esto pero veamos esto con más detalle
analicemos la matemática para que nos
sintamos mejor comprobando que este es
el caso regresemos a la definición de
torque la magnitud del torque aquí nos
vamos a estar enfocando en la magnitud
la magnitud del torque va a ser igual a
la magnitud de la fuerza que se
encuentra en esta dirección
perpendicular multiplicada por r y qué
es esto esta fuerza pues esta fuerza va
a ser igual a la masa por la aceleración
y va a ser la aceleración en esta
dirección la cual podemos verla como el
cambio en esta velocidad entre el cambio
en el tiempo y bueno estamos hablando de
magnitudes así que es la magnitud de
esta velocidad
y esto lo vamos a multiplicar por r si
multiplicamos ambos lados de esta
ecuación por delta te vamos a tener y de
hecho mejor pongo atado en diferente
color
el torque x delta t
es igual a la masa x delta de en esa
dirección perpendicular x r y esto que
va a hacer pues esto es el cambio en el
momento angular cambio en el momento
angular y esta es una analogía de lo que
ustedes pueden recordar del mundo
transnacional en el mundo transnacional
tenemos esta noción de que si tenemos la
fuerza y la multiplicamos por el tiempo
en el que estamos aplicando esta fuerza
fuerza por delta t a esta cantidad
usualmente se la denomina impulso
este va a ser igual al cambio en el
momento traslacional si no tenemos una
fuerza pues no vamos a tener un cambio
en el momento tenemos la conservación
del momento por lo que éste no va a
cambiar se va a conservar y con esto
podemos hacer algunas predicciones
bastante interesantes tenemos la misma
analogía acá el análogo de la fuerza en
el mundo rotacional store' que es la
fuerza multiplicada por el radio por esa
distancia radial si multiplicamos al
torque por la duración del tiempo que
vamos a estarlo aplicando ese va a ser
el cambio en el momento angular si no
estamos aplicando ningún torque si el
torque es cero significa que delta l es
cero no va a estar cambiando el momento
angular podemos decir que nuestro
momento angular es constante
así que si no aplicamos torque como en
los patinadores sobre hielo que ya se
encuentran girando y no están aplicando
más torque a su giro su momento angular
va a ser constante pero pueden cambiar
su velocidad de rotación al cambiar r a
cambiar el tamaño del radio obviamente
la masa no la pueden cambiar y vimos en
el vídeo anterior que una patinadora es
un sistema mucho más complicado que un
simple punto de masa como el que
dibujamos aquí que se encuentra unido a
un clavo mediante una cuerda una
patinadora o un patinador va a ser
modelado con muchos puntos de masa pero
yo espero que con esto les quede mucho
más clara la idea